franco not just a competitor but the
favorite to win the hot dog eating
contest it's the most you can eat in
five minutes so Richard I how often do
you practice for something like um I
know my you know my parents might fool
you I've been on a giant diet and
life-changing stuff dropped about a
hundred pounds in eight months awesome
so we're gonna consider this my cheat
day for the year but you know prepping
just gallons of water go you know I have
two giant inspirations first my wife
that's alright second anniversary or I
want to say hi to her and there's a
comedian I love he's a big giant fat guy
just like me Bert Chrysler and you know
if he can do it I can do it and he's
still way bigger than I am but you know
what maybe I can inspire him there you
go